-Our first guest tonight i
a Golden Globe-nominated actor
and director you know
from films such as "Loving,"
"Zero Dark Thirty,"
and "Boy Erased."
He stars in
"The Underground Railroad,
which is streaming now
on Amazon Prime Video.
Please welcome back to the sho
our friend Joel Edgerton.
How are you, Joel?
-I'm very good, mate.
I've missed you.
-I know.
-But I'm fine.
-You know, I hope you know I'm
not just blowing smoke here.
As happy as I am
that you're on the show,
it is very bittersweet
that you're not here in person
-Yeah. Yeah, it is actually.
I'd love to give you a man hug
and run in
and have a studio audience
-Yeah.
-It must be pretty boring
without a studio audience.
-I would be giving you a man hug
in congratulations.
You're a new dad.
Congratulations, Joel.
[ Laughs ]
-Yeah, thank you.
I'm very excited.
It's one of the great
silver linings of the last year.
Sort of a crazy terrible year.
I'm very happy.
-It's a perfect, perfect
silver lining.
I also know
that you're back in Australia.
Thank you for waking up at
the crack of dawn to talk to us.
And you're back doing a project,
and I imagine Australia
is very proud
of your accomplishments,
but knowing what I know
about Australians,
they also probably
want to check in with you
and make sure you're not
getting too full of yourself
-Oh, I am.
-[ Laughter ]
-I am.
[ Laughs ]
In fact, full to the brim,
some might say.
-You -- This is very --
Oh, look at that!
You got the mug we sent you.
-Thank you, by the way.
Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
-This is really --
I feel like this is really
helping our at-home audience
who misses being
in the same room.
-Just trying to bring back
the old feeling, you know?
-Hey, I want to talk to yo
about your TV show,
but there's a show that we'r
sort of obsessed with here
called "Tiny Secret Whispers,"
which stars
a different Australian actor
with the same spelling
of your name
pronounced Joel "Edgar-ton."
Do you know him?
-[ Sighs ] Yeah.
-Okay.
-I've run into him a coupl
of times at "events," you know
You know, it took me a --
I've had a bit of a --
It's been a long ride,
but I've gotten used to the idea
that he's masquerading somewhat,
at least on paper, as me.
-Has there ever been a situation
where you've really wanted
a part, and he's got it,
but for a moment,
there's confusion
and you think it's yours?
-Well, yeah, I mean,
I did get asked to auditio
for "Tiny Secret Whispers.
I tried to download
the Pumpkin...
-Butternut.
-Butternut streaming site.
But I had a lot of problem
with an Australian credit card
And, you know --
Look. To be honest,
I've checked out
a couple of clips,
and I love the actor
that plays...
I'm not a fan of Joel Edgar-ton.
-Yeah, well, that's fine.
I mean, I would imagine
that's hard for you.
[ Laughs ] I want to ask
about a real TV show
that you were in,
the real Joel Edgerton.
Your first TV gig,
you did not last long.
Your character, I should say
did not last long.
-No. [ Laughs ]
My first acting job
out of drama school,
I played Ben Mendelsohn's
younger brother,
and we were holding up
a video store.
Half the audience maybe wanted
to know what a video store is.
I was dead by 11:00 a.m.
on my first day on my job
as an actor.
11:00 a.m.
-That's not great.
-I thought, "This is the
beginning of my career."
And I was in my car
driving home going,
"I just quit my regular jo
for this, and now I'm dead."
-You mention Ben Mendelsohn.
So, I love both of you
as actors, and I mean that
And I first saw you in a film,
"Animal Kingdom,"
where both of you didn't reall
end up living very long.
Have you ever been in a projec
with Ben where either of you
have made it through
the full run time?
-No. "The King," we both die
Uh, spoiler alert.
[ Laughter ]
I think you've hit on something.
I think Ben and I
are destined --
It's sort of Romeo and Juliet,
right?
-Right. Yeah. You are the
Australian Romeo and Juliet.
-It'd be like,
"Yeah, come on, mate, let's...
Blegh."
[ Laughter ]
-That was a really,
really good impression
of Ben Mendelsohn
as either Romeo or Juliet.
Hey, I do want to ask abou
"Underground Railroad."
We'll be right back with mor
from Joel Edgerton.